For the rest of this lesson, you'll
be analyzing Udacity student data.
But, before you get started on that,
let's talk about some of the other kinds
of problems you might
solve as a data analyst.
When many people hear
the term data analyst,
they picture someone who works at a tech
company, and probably in Silicon Valley.
Many data analysts do in
fact work at tech companies.
For example, Netflix uses data
analysis to provide personalized movie
recommendations for its users.
Facebook uses it in their
newsfeed ranking algorithm.
And OkCupid uses it to predict
which people are likely to be good
romantic matches.
In addition to building these kinds of
systems, many companies also use data
analysis to publish papers or
write blog posts about their findings.
For example,
Facebook has studied the ideological
diversity of people's political posts.
They found that when posts appear
on people's newsfeeds written from
a different perspective, users
are less likely click on those posts.
OkCupid wrote a blog post about,
what are the best questions to
ask someone on a first date?
Did you know that long term
couples are very likely to agree
about whether they like horror movies?
Data analysts don't just work
at tech companies, though.
Walmart looks through their purchase
records and people's posts on
social media in order to figure
out what to stock in their stores.
Apparently, strawberry Pop-Tarts
are more likely to sell out right before
a hurricane.
Bill James is famous for
applying data analysis to baseball.
He used it to understand who
are the top performers, and
how can you best predict
future performance?
And pharmaceutical companies have
started using machine learning to
predict which chemical compounds
are most likely to make effective drugs.
Using this, they can make better
decisions about which compounds
are likely to be a good use of
the resources involved in running
a clinical trial.
If you'd like to learn more
about any of these applications,
check out the links in
the instructor notes.